Dr fauci Who has basically lied about
everything and I got a list of things
that he lied about that we're going to
get to in just a moment he went on uh on
it was Chris Matthews show and again
sorry not Chris Matthews Chris Matthews
disgraced MSNBC Guy this is Chris
Wallace disgraced Fox News guy anyway
he's got a new CNN show I guess and uh
fauci went on there uh and he sort of
doubled down on that I am the science
comment you guys remember that that very
Palpatine I am the Senate I am the
science comment so uh Chris Wallace
asked him about it he kind of backed out
and then he went right back in take a
look you have also taken some hits about
some comments you made last year here
if they get up and criticize science
nobody's going to know what they're
talking about but if they get up and
really aim their bullets at Tony fauci
well people could recognize there's a
person there there's a face there's a
vice you can recognize you see him on
television so it's easy to criticize but
they're really criticizing science
because I represent science
that's dangerous to me that's more
dangerous than the slings and the arrows
that get thrown at me
your critics accuse you of hubris they
say that you express a certainty and a
disregard
for the views of others can you
understand when you say I represent
science sure I can understand how that
could have been taken out of context and
I probably had to do it all over again
would have changed the wording a little
bit of that what I was trying to say
Chris is that what I was doing was
saying here are the data of why vaccines
are safe and effective so we should be
getting people vaccinated so when you're
criticizing me you're actually
criticizing the scientific facts it's
absolutely staggering this guy is such a
piece of work he should be studied I'd
like to commission a scientific study to
study Anthony fauci how he can take
every position on everything and still
think he's the good guy it's actually
quite remarkable uh first off when he
says that you're criticizing science
which he backed into again a lot of
people weren't criticizing him they were
criticizing the science a lot of people
were going wait a minute wait a minute
you're telling me if I wear you know a
dollar mask that was made in China that
you know isn't airtight and everything
else and germs are going out this way
and down this way and I can on a plane I
can take it off to eat for a minute but
then I have to put it back up where is
the science in that right that's what
people were asking and when people asked
that question he took that as a
criticism of him if you remember the
first year of covet and I know what they
they purposely make us all crazy so we
can't remember anything if you remember
the first year of Kobe nobody was
criticizing him nobody was people were
welcoming lockdowns we were open to all
of these ideas an awful lot of I can't
say everybody but you know the vast
majority of people also right at the end
there he's still talking about the
efficacy of the vaccines the vaccines do
not work as I said on the show yesterday
it's only my own personal experience but
I think we all have personal experience
that has some validity my entire family
parents sister Aunt Uncle cousin me
couple other people I know all got
covered last week I'm the only one not
faxed I was completely fine outside
playing basketball all day everybody
else was sick various ages some older
some younger you don't even need to know
that the anecdotal stuff to understand
that we all know now that it was sold
the vaccine was sold to us you will not
get nor transmit covid lie booster shot
you'll get lesser covid lie masks work
lie quarantines work lie it's just lie
after lie after life